depuis plus de dix ans de mystérieux
cercle apparaissent chaque été dans les
champs de blé
toujours dans le kent une région située
au sud est de londres
les scientifiques ont observé
attentivement ce phénomène qui selon eux
serait paranormal en juin dernier les
japonais se sont installés plusieurs
jours avec du matériel sophistiqué
message d'extra terrestres ou phénomènes
naturels
les chercheurs avaient tous une bonne
explication aujourd'hui un quotidien
populaire britannique today prétend
révéler la main coupable deux alerte
sexagénaire qui seraient les auteurs du
canular
il aurait pété cet après midi leurs
techniques méthodes simples et archaïque
une ficelle reliés aux deux extrémités
d'un bâton et après avoir soigneusement
a dessiné les plans dès la nuit tombée
ils écrasaient soigneusement les blés et
aujourd'hui ils jouaient les artistes
quand on a eu assez de faire des cercles
vient nous avons décidé d'améliorer
notre technique de travail est
aujourd'hui plutôt réussi mais le
mystère n'est pas totalement éclaircies
les scientifiques de renom se sont
rendus sur place et ont constaté
l'apparition mystérieuse de ces cercles
et si ces deux hommes n'étaient pas de
gentils farceur